I want to depress you just a bit,
basically just to remind you how bad
things are, and how little things have
actually changed since one of the
biggest crises of all time—the second
biggest financial crisis, really, the one
that began in 2007-2008. And so I'm going to just very quickly depress you a bit
but I promise I will get to hopeful,
positive things towards the end. And we
have a huge amount of time. So, four big
fat problems. The first I'll call the
financial problem. The finance problem.
And this is, really what I mean by this
is the problem within the financial
sector—and I'm going to be a bit
superficial here because I'm going to go
through lots of both economic thinking
and also economic history—but what I
mean by this is a kind of
financialization of finance. In other
words, finance is financing finance. And
what you see here in this curve—this is
for the UK economy, but the US economy
looks quite similar—the degree to which
the financial sector has outpaced in its
size the rest of the economy. So this is
looking at financial intermediation,
which is basically banks but also whole
shadow banking system in all forms of
different types of financial
institutions growing much faster than
the rest of the economy. And basically
this is because so much of the financial
sector has ended up just financing
finance, insurance and real estate, which
conveniently, the acronym is FIRE. And
so, you know, this often makes people
think, 'Oh god, this is terrible,' we need to
kind of definancialize and kind of fuel
industry, right? So this is also why in
some countries, industrial policy has
come back, and the idea that we need to
kind of fuel the makers. So these are the
takers. And unfortunately, this brings me
to the second problem, which is that
industry has become very financialized
itself. And by that I mean that
increasingly in many large companies, and this is data here for 466 of the S&P 500
companies, the profits being earned are
not actually being reinvested back into
production, back into the workforce—
human capital and skill, research and
development—but used for exactly the
kind of things that Larry Fink was in
theory warning about. So things
like share buybacks. And so this data
here shows you that between 2008, so
after
financial crisis, to 2017, these 466 big
companies spent over four trillion
dollars in share buybacks, which was
equivalent to 53 percent of their
profits, along with 3.1 trillion as dividends. And this would be
fine as long as they were also again reinvesting back in. But that
yellow bit there, which is the
reinvestment back into production,
including skills, has been falling. And
you see, this by the way also at the
macroeconomic level, you might know that GDP, gross domestic product, which is how
we measure output of the economy, can be broken down in different ways. One of it
is on the spending of all the different
components of the economy, so government
spending (G), business spending (I),
consumption spending and then exports.
And the I part, business investment, has
been falling. And this is not a
coincidence, right? This is precisely
because there hasn't been that
reinvestment. I'm just going to say one
thing because I often forget to say it. And
apologies if I often do these little
parentheses, but this is a huge problem
and this basically is much more of a problem than the so-called 'the
robots are taking our jobs.' It's very
interesting if you look back at the
history of economic thought, and I'll be
going through quite a bit of history in
just a minute, David Ricardo one of the
first economists ever in 1821
wrote a book called Principles of
Political Economy and Chapter 31—don't
ask me how I remember these details, I
can't remember what I did this morning—
but chapter 31 of this book that he
wrote in 1821 called 'On Machinery,' he
warned that this rise and machines were
displacing labor. He was very worried
about the effect that the rise of the
machines—today's robots—would be having
on employment and wages. But what we
ended up having for basically 200 years,
and it kind of stopped around the 1980s
and onwards, was that as long as profits
were being reinvested back into the
economy it kind of didn't matter.
Machines, yes, took jobs in one part of
the economy, but as long as profits were
invested, they reappeared in other places. And skills were also formed as an
endogenous function of that investment
process, right? Skills don't only come
from government training programs, they
also come from if you're kind of taken
care of inside the company, if you're
invested in. And this is just really
important because there's so much talk
today about the future of work and the
robots, what's going to happen, without
actually putting these numbers in this
data at the center of the picture as
just as important to confront. And this
is a corporate governance problem. So
this was problem two—sorry, little
distraction there. Problem three is that
in a time where we would really need
serious, ambitious policy—as ambitious as
the kind of policies that got us the
welfare state, or that got a man to the
moon and back again in one generation, we basically have states that have been
convinced by, well, unfortunately, by
economists—we unfortunately have lots of
influence—that at best, they can just
kind of tinker on the sidelines. You
always have to first identify the market
failure, and then you're allowed to do
something. And this kind of leads to this
very patchy view of what policy is for.
So in a moment where we're calling for
things like a green transition, I'll get
to this in a second, the fourth problem
is in fact climate change—when we need
to—in theory, we're talking about it—
approach the sustainable development
goals for real, where we have a rise in
inequality, at least relative inequality
in many countries, and there's a talk
about reforming capitalism, this idea
that you're just there patching up the
system and putting band-aids when it
goes wrong is simply not going to get us
what we need. And it's not that these
market failures don't exist. This is the
term that economists use, 'market failures,'
and you always have to identify the
market failure before policy does
anything. They do exist. So let me just
give you some examples here. When you
have positive externalities, so goods
that create these really great spillovers,
that it's hard to appropriate the
returns just for yourself, you will have
under investment by the private sector
in that area. So government comes in and
invests in things like basic research.
The opposite when businesses are
producing too much of something. That is not good, a negative externality, then
government comes in and does something like a carbon tax when you have
asymmetric information. So cute little
companies don't get enough money because
the banks don't actually know
anything about them, because they don't
have enough history. Then you might need government to come in and do SME lending.
So again, all these things happen, and this framework isn't
completely useless. But in a time where
there's at least talk about
rediscovering purpose in reforming
capitalism, and rethinking the direction,
not just the rate, these tools are part
of the problem. And fourth, as I just kind
of gave it away before, the climate
problem. This is kind of THE problem. If
we don't sort this, everything else is
kind of irrelevant. We've got twelve
years left, the IPCC report, if you
haven't read it, read it.
Greta (Thunberg), young woman, reminds us that our house is literally on fire. Second time I
use the word 'fire,' interesting you can
use it both for climate change and the
financial sector, it's probably not a
coincidence. And you know, and
unfortunately it's not just that there's
not enough spending on renewable energy,
this also is data from the IPCC, so
apparently we're only spending about 20%
of what we should be in terms of really
getting a renewable energy revolution
going. But Green is not just about
renewable energy, it's really about
transforming how our economies work. So getting some old manufacturing sectors
to reduce their material content. And the
history of capitalism, we've often
required real kind of bold demand side
policies, not just that supply push, and
we're not getting those.